Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the
question what's it like
to sleep on a bus?
And other stories from the road.
Oh yeah we've been on the road, y'all,
we've been traveling around, doing shows
and lots of bunk, bus bunk
time for introspection.
I had a horrifying
experience which I'll share
a little bit later.
Yeah so we've been--
But I also had some really
good experiences that--
Oh well share those as well.
Changed my life
as well as the life of my children.
Yeah so we've been on
the road on tour and then
I tacked some time in
North Carolina at the end
of my time and you came back
here and had a staycation
so we'll get into talking
about that a little bit
but we do want to let you know that
while we are back temporarily,
we are going back out on the road.
Yes we gonna keep telling
you about when we're gonna be
on the road and you
know what you should go
on the internets and look
around at all the fun
that we had on our, this last tour.
There's--
Well we're gonna talk
to 'em about it.
There's definitely photos though.
Yeah there's photos out there.
There's photo evidence
of the things that we did
and how much fun people had at the things
that we were doing.
Starting September 4th.
That you should come to.
September 4th,
the next leg of the tour begins.
Houston, Texas, New Orleans, Birmingham,
Jacksonville, Florida, Tampa, Florida,
then we go to Las Vegas October 19th.
November 20th, Albuquerque, New Mexico,
then Phoenix, Arizona,
Sacramento, California,
and Valley Center, California.
Go to RhettAndLinkLive.com to get tickets.
And to clarify something,
we talked about this on our Instagram,
one of those Instagram videos that we did
where we're eating tour food.
We met somebody on the road and we tend
to meet people when we're in these cities
and they tend to say things like,
oh I didn't know you were in town.
That's why we continue
talking about the shows
but then we met someone
who did know about the show
but she was like I don't have $300,
and we were like, what are
you talking about, $300?
And I think what she
was doing and what a lot
of people are doing is if you just Google
Rhett and Link concert tickets,
well some sponsored sites--
I do that every day.
Some sponsored sites where
they're reselling tickets
are gonna come up and don't
buy the tickets there.
Go to RhettAndLinkLive.com to get
the best prices on tickets.
I think we've got tickets
starting at around $30
for these upcoming shows so we're trying
to make it as affordable as possible
so that won't be an excuse.
If you don't know about
it maybe that's our fault
but if you're paying a whole lot of money
for your tickets, that might be your fault
if you're going to the wrong place.
The bus life was something
that was interesting
which we'll talk about but
also the culinary lifestyle
that we assumed while on tour was,
I can't--
Consequential.
I can't decide if it was
great or if it was horrible.
It was both.
It was great and horrible.
We had this idea and
if you happen to catch
an Instagram live, we're
talking like an hour
before our show, maybe a
little bit more sometimes.
We would sit down and
we would eat what you
or at least those of you
who voted and responded
to our Instagram post, we
ate the two most popular
signature dishes from the
most signature restaurant
at each city that we
were in according to you.
We pitted 'em against each other.
And it turns out that
those signature dishes
are not things like kale salads.
No.
As you might imagine,
they are things like, you
just increased the probability
of you having a heart
attack by at least 2%
every time you eat something,
it's that kind of meal.
I think by a certain point in the tour,
we were eating dishes that
were just called cholesterol.
Yes.
Okay we got a big styrofoam clam shell.
I open that thing up, oh
look, it's just cholesterol.
Well literally one of
'em was just fried cheese
that you dip in ranch dressing.
That was pretty great.
And you know what,
it was really good, that was in Milwaukee,
that was cheese curds.
Yeah cheese curds.
Which incidentally--
Milwaukee put a hurtin'
on me, y'all.
Milwaukee won, okay.
Ooh wee.
Milwaukee won the food contest.
Not only did they have the
best dish according to me,
I think they had the best
two dishes according to me.
Now I think, and they also had custard.
The custard, the hamburger,
and the cheese curds.
Milwaukee knows what they're
doing when it comes to eating.
Cheeseburger and custard were from Kopp's.
Once you start eating a
cheeseburger and it's really good--
Not just any cops though,
a restaurant called Kopp's.
K-O-P-P-S.
Yeah we're not taking
food from the police.
Right, well, you don't trust the police?
No that's not--
You're gonna get--
That is not what--
We gonna get civic on this podcast.
I intended to talk about.
We're gonna have some civic controversy.
We got that food from Kopp's.
Like what are you talking about from cops.
Now you're accepting food from--
Well I tried to pronounce it.
Police.
I tried to emphasize the K
and the two Ps when I said it.
Yeah and no one except
your own brain saw that.
Right but I did see it.
K-O-P-P-S.
When you're eating a cheeseburger
that's as good as that cheeseburger,
you don't merely just
taste the cheeseburger.
You eat the whole cheeseburger.
Yeah I couldn't--
Even if you do have
a whole clam shell full of curds over here
and then the way to the
custard is right next to it.
See I made a curds and whey joke.
You didn't even have to emphasize that.
I knew that you were saying W-H-E-W.
W-H-E-Y.
W-H-E-W, whew!
Now speaking of tasting,
I think I'm still tasting
what I had yesterday as my
last meal in North Carolina
because the thing that
you got to do is you got
to come back to California and
go back to a California diet
and you probably feel like
clean and light and youthful.
Matter of fact, I ate a
vegan dinner last night.
Yeah see.
I did not.
Boy my farts.
Well let's not talk about your farts.
We do that enough.
I mean , I don't wanna talk about 'em
except to say that it
ain't all peaches and cream
on this side of the table.
Okay well but your body will adjust.
You had a week's worth of
North Carolina hurtin'.
What I did is I did the
tour eating and then I went
to North Carolina and I was like,
I'm still on vacation and
I'm here in North Carolina
and I just kept on eating that way
and the meal that is
currently in my stomach
and I have actually felt it lurching.
What?
Multiple times.
Okay you didn't kill it first?
I went, my final meal was Cook Out.
Oh my gosh.
And let me tell you what I got.
I love Cook Out.
And I don't even know if
you know about this yet.
I don't even wanna hear this.
I don't know if you know about the,
all the sides that are offered.
Okay so in case you didn't
know, Cook Out is a fast food
hamburger place in the south that has,
what makes it unusual is not just the fact
that it's good food but
the sides that you can get
other than fries are
basically just a ridiculous,
there are no rules in the universe.
They've thrown all rules of
what a side is to the side
because I got, first of all
I didn't get a cheeseburger,
I got a barbecue sandwich
because I was like,
you know what, I've never
had the barbecue sandwich
from Cook Out.
I've never done that either.
I've always gotten it from Smithfield's
and we had one meal left and I was like
I haven't had a barbecue sandwich yet.
Locke and Shepherd had
never been to Cook Out.
Dang.
I already knew you were a horrible parent.
Could not remember the last
time they went to Cook Out.
'Cause Locke would have
been a lot younger.
You hit him on the head every time
you take him to Cook Out.
So I got a barbecue sandwich.
Like Men In Black.
And then the side that I got, of course,
one of the sides was a corn dog.
Right.
Because that's a side.
Nuggets can be a side, you get nuggets?
No, the other side was
a chicken quesadilla.
But you just got three--
I just got three mains.
But that's what makes it so crazy.
They got chicken quesadilla,
they actually have enchiladas
as sides too is what--
Now you don't say that word right.
Quesadilla?
The other one.
Enchilada?
Yeah, it's not an inch, it's an ench.
Enchilada.
It's an E, not an I.
You can't be talking
to people about the way
to pronounce words, man.
Enchilada.
It's ehn-chilada if you wanna get--
You say inchilada.
Inchilada.
It's funny right.
But go ahead, we know what you mean.
Well then you should peench me
and tell me that I'm saying it wrong.
I'll peench you.
But I didn't get, where I drew the line is
I didn't get a milkshake 'cause hey have
over 40 different flavors
of milkshakes including one
in July, a watermelon milkshake,
watermelon shake that has
pieces of watermelon in it
that's only served
between July and August.
It's great, it's crazy.
It's crazy and so that--
And it's a small place.
Have you ever looked through the window
at them makin' all that stuff?
There's like one person in
there just spinning around.
It's like a--
Like a cartoon.
Well I've seen multiple
people but there's only room
for one person.
I saw one girl.
I think you saw six girls
but they were in the space
of one girl.
And do you know how
some Cook Outs have a
table outside of them?
Yeah.
This Cook Out
that was somewhere between
the beach and RDU had nothing.
It was just like we do not
expect you to stick around.
Well.
So I just drove across the street
to an abandoned parking
lot, which there's so much--
Space.
Abandoned buildings.
Down east.
There's just nothing there,
there's nothing there
between the beach and
Raleigh, there's nothing.
I used to drive that every
week to see my in-laws.
There was a post-apocalyptic
type of vibe to it.
From time to time--
Except for the Cook Out
and the Bojangle's.
I'm tasting either
a barbecue sandwich or a
corn dog or a quesadilla
in no particular order.
I can't believe they have enchiladas.
I did not, I would have bet against that.
Well I'm not confirming that.
Lance, we were with Lance
and Lacey and Lance told me,
he may have meant quesadilla
because when I got there
I saw quesadilla and just got it.
The menu's so big, I didn't
wanna then continue reading
to see if they had enchiladas as well.
How was the barbecue sandwich?
Solid, very good.
It's--
Have sauce already on it?
They asked me if I wanted
slaw and Texas Pete on it,
I said, well, who do you think I am?
Texas Pete on it huh?
Yes.
I would have gotten it but--
It was very good.
Steamed bun.
Texas Pete is not
a barbecue sauce.
And do you know that,
yeah, well 'cause it's got,
you mean does it already
have like vinegar,
yeah it's got some sort of
vinegar sauce in the meat.
Okay.
Do you know,
Bojangle's is also now serving
a pulled pork sandwich.
It's on the menu, I didn't get that.
Really?
And I'm sorry I have to
throw somebody under the bus,
just quickly let me do this.
Atlantic Beach, on Atlantic Beach,
which is technically an outer bank.
Emerald Isle and Atlantic Beach,
they're all on this island.
Well there's a Bojangle's on that island
and I was staying on that
island for a few days.
And I took Shepherd to Bojangle's,
I haven't been to Bojangle's yet.
I get to Bojangle's at Atlantic Beach,
I get in line and you know how they have,
the only place in the world that does the,
Bojangle's is the only place
in the world that does the line
where you gotta go around
like you're getting ready
to go on a ride.
It switches back.
Oh not in the car, you're
talking about in the restaurant.
In the restaurant there's a switch back
and then you get up
there and then you order
and they say it into the microphone.
It's awesome.
Just wondering why they're
still doing that but--
That's like an amusement park ride too,
it's like buckle up.
The first thing that threw
me off is I'll get in line
and there's a murmur
going through the line
and it's that they're out of dirty rice,
which I wanted dirty rice.
I was gonna get dirty rice and beans.
Cajun pintos.
I love the fact
that made its way back through the line.
They're out of dirty rice,
what are we gonna do?
They're out of dirty rice.
The rollercoaster's broke.
Should we leave?
Should we leave, should we
go back to the mainland?
Should we go to Morehead City?
Those kinds of things
are happening and then,
I'm like okay well, I don't
have to get dirty rice.
45 minutes later--
What?
Is when I was receiving my food.
45 minutes later.
This place, I love Bojangle's
but the one in Atlantic Beach
is so mismanaged that it is a disgrace
to the name of Bojangle's.
It is, 'cause Locke and his cousins went
and they also had to wait 45
minutes at a different time.
Different time?
I realize that
it's peak season, but there was--
You sure you weren't going to Jobangle?
There's 11 people in line.
There were 11 people in
line and some of them
were like three people
together as a party.
It wasn't 11 different groups,
it was like four different
groups, 45 minutes.
Did you band together
with those people and--
Oh I'm not done.
They're out of dirty rice, I get up there,
I order, they're still out
of dirty rice at that point
and I didn't even ask for it.
They're out of honey mustard.
Gah.
Hey man post-apocalyptic.
Then we get our tea, of
course we got sweet tea.
Jessie wanted, she said bring
me back an unsweetened tea
and then Shepherd and I were
like we're gonna get sweet tea
because we're here.
When in Rome.
We sit down and Shepherd's
like I think I got Mom's tea
and he says let me taste, and
he taste another, says no,
and then he tastes mine, says
Dad these are all unsweetened.
I was like Shepherd, this is
just your 10 year old palate.
Let me taste them.
They're all unsweet.
I go back up and I say
sorry, you put unsweet tea
in these sweet teas, he's like okay.
45 minutes later.
That happened in about seven minutes,
it wasn't too long.
Okay.
He fills 'em back up, we go back down
and Shepherd says Dad
they're still unsweet.
I taste 'em, he's right.
They have not put any
sugar in the sweet tea.
I begin to see people who've
already waited 45 minutes
for their meal getting up
and looking at their tea.
There's an old man walking
by, he's talking to himself.
I was like, the tea's not sweet is it?
He didn't even hear me, he was like .
He goes up, he gets his tea,
and then there's a woman
back there, she's like,
y'all, the tea's not sweet.
This is bad.
I mean this is like--
They forgot to put sugar in the tea.
This is the start of a
riot in North Carolina.
If there's a Bojangle's
representative listening,
send help to the one
in Atlantic Beach, man,
because I'm not gonna go to it anymore.
I don't wanna ruin, the food is so good.
I mean when Bojangle's
runs out of dirty rice--
But I don't wanna wait an hour for it.
Honey mustard, you need
to air drop some supplies.
And I believe in--
Air drop a manager in there.
I believe that it might
be actual sacrilege
to serve sweet tea that's not sweet.
I think those people might go to hell.
Me too.
I think that might be an unforgivable sin.
Right, especially when they're
like no, but this one is.
And if you do it twice, yes, yes,
you go to the third level of hell.
Sorry for that little rant,
I didn't expect to do that,
but I was really upset, very upset.
I would be afraid.
With those things
happening at a Bojangle's,
I would literally, I would be
like, kids, we gotta get out
of here 'cause something
bad's gonna happen.
Like, someone is gonna get too upset
and there's gonna be like,
they're gonna be rippin' paper bags
and I don't know, throwing tenders.
Yeah.
Well they don't call 'em tenders--
They call 'em supremes.
Supremes.
They also have homestyle tenders.
Yeah they're not hot.
They don't have the spice in them.
They're for the children.
Yeah I saw a full-grown man order those.
For the weak.
I shook my head at that guy.
For the weak men
and children.
'Cause it's not that hot.
Oh man so you're hurtin'.
I feel good now that
I got that out though.
You got that Cook Out in you.
I got this, man, it was like,
it was beets and yams and
they have this thing--
Yum.
They had a thing
called barbecue and it was--
They had a thing called barbecue.
It was made out of mushrooms.
Where was this at?
Cafe Gratitude.
Oh, that place.
We talked about this place
and when you order off the menu--
I like that place.
It's adjectives like whole and complete
and serene and when you
order you're supposed to--
Whole with a W or just H-O-L-E?
Put this in your hole.
We're having a real--
Your mouth hole.
Homonym of an episode here aren't we?
Well sometimes, man.
You gotta clarify.
There were no cops there.
It was, what was I saying again?
Whole.
Oh, yeah, when you order
you say I am devoted.
Yeah.
And then you get a dish
called devoted.
I have trouble.
I have trouble with that
system but I appreciate it.
I did it.
I appreciate what
it's trying to do.
Trying to give you gas.
And I'm not talkin' about--
And it's succeeding.
It's not at the volume, it's the flavor.
It's the snet, snet, the scent.
All right I mean we got more to talk about
in terms of our tour so let's switch gears
to going back to the tour.
But first--
Bus gears.
But first we wanna let you know
that you can grab these Ear Biscuits mugs.
You can literally grab
them, there's a handle.
Look at this.
You can also figuratively
grab them at Mythical.store.
When your ears are drinking our mouths,
your lips can be drinking from our mugs.
Mythical.store.
Thical.store.
We will--
Did a little--
It could have been quesadilla.
Enchilada come up?
It could have been breading.
It could have been the
little hard breading
on the stick at the bottom of a corn dog.
That sticks with you awhile, you know,
and I always eat the--
Oh you nibble that stuff off.
Oh that's the best part.
You nibble nibble nibble.
Listen.
You nibble that stick.
I would buy sticks
of just the hard, crusty batter.
You know what you can do is you can go
through the trash can of a Cook Out.
Crusty sticks.
You can go through
the Cook Out trash can.
Crusty sticks.
And get out the corn dog sticks.
No but people eat 'em in
their cars and at home.
Nobody sticks around.
But when you're driving
out of the parking lot,
you throw it in the trash can.
I gotta go to the Corn Dog Castle
for that refuse bin.
Mythical.store.
Get it.
Before we get back into the story,
we do wanna let you know
that this is the next to last
Ear Biscuits before we're
taking a short summer break.
We're taking a three week break.
Am I right, Kiko?
Three weeks without Ear Biscuits.
Find another podcast, no
don't find another podcast.
Listen to old Ear Biscuits,
do that in the three weeks
that we're not here.
Don't get hooked on anybody else now.
And then we'll be back
with more, so next to last,
we've got one more next week
and then a three week break
and we'll be back.
I'll quickly go through
the rhythm of tour.
Because I think it can be romanticized
and there's many ways to do it,
I mean we're spoiled
on a number of fronts.
First of all I just wanna
brag about everybody
who came out to this leg
of the tour and saw us.
You guys were super
supportive and welcoming,
and even, I'm always fascinated
and we're so analytical
when it comes to anything we
create or any time we perform,
like the moment we're
done putting something out
into the world or we come
backstage after something,
we're immediately
assessing how well it went.
And it never fails to surprise me how
different audiences are different.
Well how all audiences are
a little bit different,
the things that as a whole
that resonate with them.
Some audiences are really,
they like to cheer,
some audiences like to laugh,
some audiences do both.
Some like to talk.
Some like to talk to us and I think we,
there are cues that we
give that welcome that
and sometimes at the start of a show,
we kinda, we're a little
more open than other times.
And we made it a point
to try a few new songs
and the banter in
between, that's our moment
to see if we can create
something new every single time,
give or take.
We talked about how when
comedians or musicians tour,
a lot of times they have
to win over the audience
and we never have to do that
because people who show up
are dedicated Mythical Beasts
so there's this comfort level
and so like I said, we're
spoiled on that front.
We also have a bus that we travel in.
Now when the bus goes
a really long distance
in between shows, we do fly but
we finally realized it took,
for most of the Tour of
Mythicality we didn't do this
but we started to realize
towards the end that hey,
we can sleep on the bus,
this can actually be fun.
This might be the best
part of the whole thing.
Well maybe not.
For a 6'7" young man.
Well considering that the bunks are 6'6".
Yeah.
In length.
But we are spoiled to have a
bus that has sleeping bunks.
A nice bus.
And then it pulls
a trailer with merch and stuff behind it
and so us and the crew,
we basically traveled
on a bus the whole time, I
also brought my kids Lily
and Lincoln along with us
on this leg of the tour.
But just having a bus
like that and not having
to sleep in a van or out of a
crappy hotel or something was,
we're spoiled.
And I don't know if this is
necessarily the case with,
like a band that would be going around.
I guess they do stop somewhere to shower
but we do .
You got that corn dog crust coming up.
We do also, so basically,
as soon as the show's over,
we have our meet and greet,
we usually don't get out
of the town and start, the
bus doesn't start rolling
until after midnight, maybe 12:30.
And then we roll into the next town,
most of us go to sleep immediately
or within an hour or so
and then you don't set
an alarm or anything,
you just wake up.
Well you said we roll into town
and most of us go to sleep.
No, once the bus starts
moving, we go to sleep
and then it's driving to the place.
Oh roll out of town.
Roll out of town, yes.
Like an hour after we leave,
everybody's pretty much
asleep and so then,
you don't set an alarm,
you just wake up at some,
you go to bed that late, you
going to bed at one, 1:30.
Most people are gonna wake up at nine, 10.
I'm gonna wake up at 10 or 11.
And then--
And realize the bus
is no longer moving and that
everyone has vacated the bus
except for me and my children.
Usually the Neals are
the last off the bus.
I was the last off the bus
one time but most of the time,
you guys, I get up and
I see all your shoes,
you're still there, I'm
like oh they're still there.
But then there's Gary, our
tour manager has created
basically a map or a very
simple set of directions
for this is how you get to the hotel.
Here's your hotel key, you do have a hotel
'cause you're gonna go
there and basically shower
and we would just
basically shower and then--
We'd have a couple of
hours to do something.
Go out and eat lunch and
then maybe walk around
or if there are scooters,
we would scoot around town--
Oh yeah.
For a couple of hours
before we have to get back for
sound check and sign posters
for the meet and greet and all that.
I'll tell ya, Denver's
a good place to scooter.
Very good.
They got this river there
that's got rapids all
in it and then there's,
it's fancy, all the paths
they got around this river.
Yeah that was, I'd say
Denver was the scooter,
scooting highlight.
Yeah.
Scooting capital of the
world, you might say.
Scooter low-light was probably--
Omaha.
Omaha I would say.
More for Britton than for us because,
man, he took a tumble.
Well and I saw the whole
thing in slow motion.
Now let me just say that
right before Britton
had his incident on the scooter--
He hit a hole.
I was thinking about, we were in Omaha
and there's also a giant river,
is it the Missouri River,
is that what that was?
Yeah.
Coming through Omaha and
we're going all around
and scooting up and down these paths
and there's this little park next
to the Conagra campus
there and we're going
around this pond and I was
thinking after we'd been out
for an hour and a half, I was like,
I'm kinda surprised
that no one has fallen.
And I actually in my mind
was like, kinda surprised
that one of the kids, and
when I say one of the kids,
I kinda throw Britton,
Britton's more a kid than--
He's 19 but--
We could be his dad.
Right, he's only five
years older than Lincoln.
And I was like I'm surprised
that one of them hasn't fallen
on these scooters yet and
literally three minutes later--
You voodooed him.
I didn't say anything.
Did you stab a doll?
I'm going over this bridge in this park,
this sort of arched
bridge and we get to the,
and Britton's in front of me
and it was just this change
in the surface, this little bump.
Sometimes all it takes is a little bump.
It was a hole 'cause I hit it too.
Yeah there's a drop off.
It was a drop off and then
a bump on the other side
'cause it was like this
depressed area of bricks.
And he hit it and I saw
him begin to lose control
and then he over corrected
and then he came back
again and then he flew off
of of the scooter at full speed
and did a pretty athletic
move to fall down and roll
into a back flip and
then land in the grass.
But I could see on his face
immediately that he was shaken.
All I could see as I was
coming over the bridge horizon
were his feet in the air.
Oh so you saw that.
Yeah.
And then he was rollin'.
Tore up his elbow and one of his hands.
It's like hold on man,
those are your money makers.
You're a guitarist.
Right and he had a show
and we had a show, well he
had a show the next night.
Right because we didn't
have a show that night.
Now thankfully Jenna who
is here was also there
at the time because Link
and I just proceeded
to laugh and make fun of Britton.
As he just sat there and shook.
And--
We knew he wasn't dead.
He wasn't really hurt.
He wasn't actively bleeding.
There wasn't anything broken.
Well he was actively bleeding.
He was actively bleeding.
In fact he got blood all over his pants.
He was shaken, he got a little pale.
He was a little bit in shock but we knew
that he wasn't permanently
injured so we laughed.
And that's what guys do, man.
And then Jenna came in
and was thinking straight
and strategically.
What was that magic fluid
you started pouring on his
arm, like contact solution or something.
It was just water.
Oh it was just water.
Now she sacrificed--
Glasses cleaner.
Her glasses cloth.
Oh it was cloth, I thought the,
when you said I'm gonna
use my glasses cleaner,
I thought all of that
liquid up until this moment,
I thought she was pouring
glasses cleaner all over his arm.
I was like hmm that's like MacGyver.
But that's also poison.
I thought it was alcohol.
No I think that like--
Which is why I was just
sitting on the side laughing.
'Cause who am I, who knows
what I would have poured
in his wound.
Right.
Hey let me pee on it, man,
I think when you get stung
by some asphalt, you gotta pee on it.
Right yeah, like a jellyfish.
But--
I probably could have
convinced him, that would have been funny.
Jenna took care of him
and we did all scoot back
to a place where we could
drop the scooters off
'cause we were outside of
the scooter offloading area
that we couldn't, the
app would not accept us
to just stop where we were.
But he ended up being okay.
He looked kinda cool
playing the next night
with a large bandage around his elbow.
He got some sympathy points or whatever.
But anyway in terms of the schedule,
yeah we typically do
something for a couple hours.
Usually no one would get hurt and then,
we'd show up at the venue,
we'd do a soundcheck,
we'd sign posters for the meet and greet
and then we'd just sit backstage.
We'd eat our food and so it ended up being
like three hours of just
kinda sitting around backstage
and then doing the show and
the whole thing starts over.
But you would really
get into the rhythm of,
I can't wait to get back to the bus.
I know that was Lily's favorite part.
There's something about
climbing on this bus
and at some points the
bunks were three high
and at some points they were two high.
When they're three high you
cannot sit up in your bunk.
You just gotta roll in and
roll out like a log roll.
But we got the two, they gave me and you--
I still could--
The two high.
Yeah and some of the
crew but the youngsters
got the three high.
There is something like cozy,
it's like a cozy hideout
and you lay down in the thing
and then you pull your curtain
closed and you Velcro it
and then you can take your pants off.
Hmm.
Take whatever you got
on off if you want to.
I wasn't naked.
I had the really comfortable pants though
that I left on 'cause
it's almost like a blanket
in and of itself.
There was a little light in there,
then you can set up your
earphones and you can listen
to some, a playlist to help you sleep.
Or you can just go to sleep to the murmur
and the rustle of the bus.
And that was a lot of fun
but I started playing,
well every night I would go to sleep with,
I downloaded this playlist
on Spotify called Deep Sleep.
And I would listen to that thing.
And it was like eight or nine hours
of just ambience, sleep-inducing--
And then some pianos over top of that.
And what headphones are
you employing for this?
My Bose noise-canceling in ear headphones,
not a sponsor.
Right 'cause you can't use the AirPods
'cause they would run out eventually.
I actually did use AirPods sometime,
and they would just fall out of my ears
and then I'd wake up in
the middle of the night
searching for an AirPod
because I'd be too anxious
that I'd lost it forever.
So does this preclude you
from sleeping on your side?
I would roll all over and
sometimes the whole cord
would just tangle around
my waist like a belt.
But what about ear pain when you,
I'm an exclusive side sleeper.
I'm a back sleeper but I
did sleep on my side some
and there is inner ear pain
where you're smooshing it in.
That's why I can't listen
to things in the ears.
That's not the worst
thing about it though.
But I will tell you what is.
And that's when you're listening
to an eight hour playlist
of just instrumental
ambient music which is great
to send you into a deep stupor.
But you only do this while traveling.
You don't do this at home.
I do not.
And I'm laying there sleeping
and then all of a sudden,
a woman says to me,
"Don't leave me,"
and I woke up terrified.
And I look around, there's no woman.
Right.
There's nobody talking on
this deep sleep playlist.
Much less singing, this is instrumental.
And I'm like, I dreamt that
a woman said don't leave me.
I went back to sleep.
Was it Christy's voice?
But I was kinda, it was
more dramatic than that.
It was a dramatic Christy--
It was a dramatic,
I don't know, it was a lot of need in it.
It was very disconcerting
and I don't remember dreaming anything
but I was able to go back to sleep
and then I went deep again, nothing.
Wake up next day fine.
Fast forward to the next
night, same routine,
I go to sleep, I've been
asleep for a few hours.
And then all of a sudden, the woman.
Don't leave me.
She returned and this time
I woke up and I'm like,
okay, I know, is there a ghost in there?
I don't know what's going on and I'm like
it's the frickin' playlist.
In the middle of a nine hour playlist
that's just instrumental
there is one sound snippet
in the middle of a song
where a woman says,
"Don't leave me," and that is terrifying.
It's a--
Spotify, you gotta remove
that from the playlist,
and a matter of fact, I found it,
because the third time I was like,
you know when this happens,
I'm gonna take a screenshot
and I'm gonna remember so I
can remember where this is.
It's just an Easter egg, man.
It's an Easter egg that
people who commit fully
to the playlist experience.
Allana Johnson, Breathing Star.
Yeah it's Allana.
Don't leave me.
I like to feel needed and wanted.
Not when you're in a deep sleep, man,
it's like what, I'm not leaving you, girl.
I'm laying here asleep!
You freak me out, man.
So then I told the people
at the show that night
and then there was a good
runner about don't leave me.
Yeah it really worked, it did.
That's the type of stuff
you live for, you know,
getting scared, the crap scared out of me.
What I was thinking was
gonna happen is the music
was gonna drop out completely
and some woman was gonna say,
"Don't leave me."
And then it was gonna come back in
'cause that would wake me up for sure.
So that was a low-light
but I would say a highlight
of the tour besides again like I said,
we're so spoiled by, it was
just a great audience reception
and it was great to connect
with so many Mythical Beasts
and to get even more of an
idea of what makes them tick
and what makes them laugh, you know.
It turned out to be very
special for me because
Lily and Lincoln were there.
I didn't think Lily was
gonna be able to come
but then the fact that they
both were able to come,
we should say that Locke was gonna come
but then because of--
He had like five basketball
games in that 11 week period
so he would have left his boys hanging.
Yeah he couldn't do it.
But he was obviously invited
and there was a chance
he may come and then
hopefully in the future
he'll be able to do something like that
because it was so special
for me and my kids,
and of course Lando's too young,
Shepherd's probably too young
because they need to be supervised more.
They have to fend for themselves.
The kids have to fend for themselves.
But you know, I realized
that it was such a sweet
and special time for me and
Lily and Lincoln afterward
when I started to reflect
on the fact that really
the only time that we spend
that much time together,
like every waking hour
for 10 days straight,
the only time we do that is
if we go on a family vacation.
Right.
You know,
and a family vacation is
a totally different vibe
than being on tour because
everybody's in a different mode
when vacation is happening
but when we were on tour,
we're in tour mode so we're
working and we're doing things
and I think they kinda
rose to the challenge,
I wouldn't call it a
challenge but they kinda rose
to the occasion of hey,
we're part of the crew.
They rolled some posters
and they would hand 'em out
at the meet and greets.
They didn't roll posters
every night, sorry Jenna.
But they felt, they were treated as equals
and I could definitely
see that in their takeaway
as they reported back to Christy and Lando
when we got back home
how much they enjoyed it
and they talked about tour life.
I was hopeful but I didn't
wanna be too hopeful,
you know me, I think,
oh when they get back,
they're gonna have this
perfect idea of what tour was
and it's gonna be the
most influential thing
in their entire lives so
I didn't wanna go into
full dad Link mode with my expectations
so I was pleasantly surprised
that it meant so much
to them and they said
they had a great time
and I think just spending
that amount of time together,
you really get to, again, when
you're not in vacation mode,
it was a great opportunity for
us to get to know each other,
'cause I was able to
observe them interacting
with the other members
of the crew, and, okay,
when do they choose to pipe
up and what do they choose
to say and what are their
perspectives on things.
It's something that I
don't have the benefit of
that often and actually thought about,
I got a little jealous
of Christy over the years
who as difficult and
demanding as it was for her
to homeschool the kids
for all those years,
they've been at public school for,
this is their third year now
but and the same with Jessie,
it's like, I got to see
a little bit of a side
of them that I think Christy
and I'm guessing Jessie
got to see of our kids
that we don't get to see
as much when it's not like
you're constantly with them.
You know?
And then at the end of 11
days, then you're good.
You don't have to do it anymore.
Yeah right.
But it just turned out to
be a very special time.
And you know what, they said
that they enjoyed getting
to know you more in kind of a work mode.
Unprompted, they were like, you know what,
I actually have a different view of Rhett,
and I'm like, and I told
them about my vacation theory
and I extended, I was
like, yeah a lot of times
when you see Rhett it's in family
or if we do vacations together,
it's in that type of mode
and it was just like,
the thing that, I think
it was Lincoln who said,
he was like, maybe it was Lily.
She was like, you know what, you guys,
I thought it was cool
to get to see you guys
actually enjoy hanging
out with each other.
I was like well have you
ever watched our show?
But I think she knows
that that's the show.
But it's not a show, I
think is what she said.
I enjoyed you guys enjoying each other.
Well I think--
I didn't know what I thought
about, my first thought
when they were gonna
go, I was like, oh no,
we're gonna have to worry about them
and not be able to get into
places because they're too young
and et cetera, et cetera,
but my thought was--
You talkin' about strip clubs again?
Yeah yeah yeah.
My thought--
I've never been in a strip
club just for the record.
That was a joke.
My thought was--
No judgment if you have, hey listen,
let's change the subject.
I'm just--
Why you talkin' about strip clubs?
I didn't say it, didn't
say anything about that.
I was talking about bars.
18 and up or 21 and up, you know.
There's some establishments
where children are not allowed.
Right.
So but I actually think that having,
and I think that Britton also
contributed to this as well.
Yeah.
Having younger people there
definitely significantly
changes the dynamic
'cause we have a tendency to just be
in work mode like all the time.
Now sure, oh let's go
get on these scooters
and run around, if it was just me and you
and it has been just
me and you and gone out
and just scooted around or whatever,
but I think that something
about having kids there,
it lightens the atmosphere a little bit.
It's not that we don't know how
to have fun with each other,
it's just that we have
so many things going on
that there's at any moment we could stop
and start talking about
some work-related thing
or some project and even
if it's a creative thing,
we'll do it in a very serious manner,
and so I think that they
actually kinda change
the dynamic, the group
dynamic, just being kids,
just being silly.
Yeah and kinda having
this vibe of wanting them
to have a good time so
electing to do more things
to have a good time versus
just maybe I'll just sit
in the hotel or let's talk about work.
And I do wanna say I really
do appreciate the way
that you included them
and it was unfortunate
but totally understandable
that Locke wasn't able
to come but the fact that you
were able to extend yourself
to include them as much as you did,
they without me asking, they noticed
and I really appreciated that too.
I thought that was very gracious and yeah,
I think fun was had by everyone
except for maybe Britton's elbow.
And I think it's cool just in conclusion
that a lot of people ask us,
what do your kids think about what you do?
And it was just, it meant a lot to me
that they thought it was
fun and cool to be a part
of something their dad
was doing, you know?
There weren't any eye rolls.
It was like hey, this is--
And that--
This is cool.
I do want, and if Locke can't
go in the next couple years
or whatever then hopefully
Shepherd will be able to.
I do want them to be able
to experience it because...
Yeah, it's like, there's a different feel
than just saying oh I'm gonna come on set
when you have a guest
that I'm interested in
or something like that,
it's a different thing.
I'm glad that--
We'll see.
We had the opportunity
to give 'em that gift
and I believe that they'll
remember that trip forever
and that's what I hope for so.
That was my highlight but I
wanna hear about your vacation
too because we haven't
had a chance to talk.
Yeah so we got through with the tour.
I flew directly from
Minneapolis to the beach
in North Carolina to spend
time with my wife's family.
Her parents and her sister
and husband and kids.
And we were going to spend a
couple days in one location
and a few days in another location.
So you may, if you
followed me on Instagram,
shout-out to @rhettmc on Instagram,
a very dynamic Instagram
account from time to time.
You may have seen my,
what went down on the day
of July 4th.
I don't know if you saw any of this.
The only thing I saw was
you looking for horses
which you can leave for Instagram.
After that I was like okay.
Oh you missed, you missed,
that was just the warmup story.
You didn't see the fireworks show?
Uh-uh.
Oh brother.
Okay so I've talked about this before.
I've talked about how my
father-in-law used to get firework,
together, he would produce the show,
i.e. he would finance the show
and then I would go down to--
He would executive produce.
I would go down
to South Carolina and buy the fireworks
and then spend all day
wiring them together
with extra fuses and stuff,
creating as crazy of an
amateur fireworks show
as you can get away with, right?
Illegally in North Carolina.
Well, it's illegal in
the sense that going 62
in a 55 is or 64 in a 55 is because--
Okay.
No.
On July 4th--
They turn a blind eye.
They turn a blind eye, in
fact, I've had the cops
and when I say cops in this
setting, I mean C-O-P-S,
drive by while I was in
the process of lighting
a crap ton of fireworks, lighting them.
And they just kinda like nod at ya,
it's like oh it's Fourth of July.
So--
You're American, I'm American.
Aw man I'll have to show you.
I've still got video of some of it
because we were renting
a, we were staying at
one of my father-in-law's
houses that he's got down there.
They have a property company
that's got different houses
that you can rent so we
kinda reserved one of them.
And it was one that was on the sound
that had a very long dock
that went out into the sound.
I was like this is perfect,
we're gonna take all the
fireworks out onto the dock
and light them.
Oh no.
But I was like I'm not gonna take all day
to get the extra fuse,
I was like just get me a powerful lighter
that is a wind-proof
like torch kinda lighter
and then we'll just figure
it out in the moment.
You know just take some
stuff out there and light it
and then string some stuff together.
You're not used to all that prep anymore.
You don't work hard anymore.
I'm not gonna do the work.
And also I had Locke and
then his two teenage cousins
and then my brother-in-law
so we had a lot of help
to get the things out on
the dock and first of all,
I don't remember exactly
how much money we spent
on fireworks 10 years ago which
is the last time I did this
but my father-in-law
went a little bit nuts
with the amount of stuff that he bought.
He sent one of his employees
down to South Carolina.
The guy came back and
he had like a twin cab
or like quad cab truck or whatever
and the whole backseat was
just stacked to the ceiling
with fireworks, like this guy
had of been in an accident
and there was a little spark--
Oh my gosh.
He would have created a crater.
Is he a smoker?
No not a smoker, he wasn't
a smoker on that day.
But anyway we set these
things off and the cool thing
about setting the
fireworks off in the sound
is you've got all these people watching
from, of course, we've got
my family that's up there
on the deck watching from the house
and then you've got everyone
else that just come out
to the back of their
houses all on the sound,
on both sides, to watch all
the fireworks happening.
Oh.
So by about--
Did you warn 'em?
No no, by about the
second round of lighting
a couple of these, they
basically come in these boxes
of fireworks that have, it's
just a box with a fuse on it
and it has got a bunch
of mortars built into it.
Sometimes it's 10 shots,
sometimes it's 40 shots, right?
Anywhere in between, it
basically is its own little show.
We had like 50 of these things.
So there were times where
we were lining up six
and twisting two fuses together and three
of us would light 'em at
the same time and then run.
And by the time we did the
second round of these things,
we had an audience.
People can tell when you've gotten through
with a little bit, one round, right.
It's like last firework goes
off and then it gets quiet
and then all of a sudden
all these people from wider
and wider radius would go, woo hoo hoo!
Woo!
And then we had an audience.
That sounds like a rebel yell.
And then there's other
people doing fireworks
at their houses.
But then by about the
fourth, and first of all,
there were like 15 rounds that we did
but by the third or fourth round,
one guy yells out, "You win!"
It's funny.
And I was like
that's all I needed to hear.
It's funny, yeah.
That's specifically what
you were after, right?
You win.
Not that's awesome, he said
exactly what you wanted to hear.
Well no I told my
father-in-law, I was like,
when the guy said all
the things, I was like,
we are going to have
the best firework show.
We're gonna win fireworks, boys.
In this area.
Non-professional, that is.
It's funny you talk about
the woos because last year,
we're watching fireworks from our house,
from our bedroom deck, we just happened to
through some trees see
the fireworks display
of the local high school.
And we realized and we ran upstairs.
This year the kids watched 'em
but we were hanging out downstairs,
we were with some friends
and you seen one firework,
you seen 'em all.
I'm sorry that that's my
attitude but last year--
Yeah you didn't see my--
We were so elated
because fireworks started
going off and it was me,
Christy and the kids up there
and all of a sudden behind me,
I just hear woo!
And I turn around and Christy's like what?
I'm from Kinston, man.
Yeah.
I'm like and that's almost down
to the beach where you were
is where she grew up
and it's like that's a,
that's just an instinctive southern thing
when you see something on fire in the sky.
Woo!
Yeah well here's the thing,
the reason it's, not only is it better
than a professional show
because you're the one
in control of it, but
you're so close to it.
Let me--
So unsafe.
I'm gonna show,
this is Locke filming
us lighting one round.
Whoa!
This is all on Instagram.
Good gracious.
Oh my word.
He's filming--
The wrong part of it.
He's filming the gazebo.
I critiqued him.
I'll show you when I filmed it.
Even when he films the fireworks,
he's filming just below the fireworks.
Look at that.
Is the pier catching on fire?
Well we'll get to that in a second.
Oh, what?
I'll show you one that I filmed.
This is, now, you can see
a flame down there, right?
You see that flame?
Yeah.
What is that flame?
Well, it's one
of the things, I didn't
put this on Instagram
'cause I was a little
embarrassed about this.
The zooming is--
That's Locke.
A bit nauseating.
Now when I filmed,
ran back.
Guys, a bunch of rednecks out
there with their shirts off.
My goodness.
Now I'll show you.
That's one set?
Oh my gosh.
These are huge.
That's huge.
These are massive, you
never seen this before.
You never been present for one of these?
Uh-uh.
I mean like it's a legit firework show.
You thought I was talking
like little bottle rockets?
I didn't know it was that big.
No no, and listen,
you're right next to it.
In fact, we had--
You didn't spray?
We had five leftover and we took 'em
to the other beach house which is up
on the Intracoastal Waterway
like up on the Neuse River.
Okay.
And there's another dock.
We take it out on that and
I lit like six that night.
This is Saturday night
so July 7th I guess.
Just a couple nights ago
and technically I think
they're illegal by that point.
Oh yeah they're not turning a blind eye.
But we had more.
You're going out on a dock so as to--
For the view.
Oh you're not doing that
so if it catches on fire,
the whole will just burn into
the water and then it's safe.
Well that does help.
Because I'll get back
to how we had to handle
that fire in a second.
There was one where the
wind was coming back
towards us and they
don't always go as high
as they should and
there's one that blew up
and then it blows up into a
bunch of different pieces,
then it blows up again
in smaller explosions.
I swear there was one that happened where
the second small explosion,
I'm the one closest
to the action 'cause I light it,
then I kinda go down the stairs,
'cause this dock had like two levels
and then I'm kinda watching it.
One came, I swear that I was getting hit
with the little sparks.
It's not safe.
As I said on the Instagram, I gave a,
my wife made me do a disclaimer.
Jessie was like you
need to do a disclaimer
so people don't do this and I said,
my wife wants me to give you a disclaimer.
Do not do this unless
you're a redneck is what--
Is what I said.
As cool as this looks and
as much fun as I'm having--
You will hurt yourself
if you're not a redneck.
But so, fire time,
so Jessie first of all she says,
"Do you have a fire extinguisher?"
Right before we're
getting ready to do this
and I'm like, "No."
And I was like we're
doing it over the water.
She's like you need to
have a fire extinguisher
and I was like okay so
they had one at this house
like underneath the sink and what happens
after these things go off as you can see,
it's so hot that sometimes
they just end up catching fire
after all the stuff's gone and so,
I'm looking at that and
me and Chris were trying
to figure out what to do so we ran
and got the fire extinguisher
but they basically expended,
it was one of the fire
extinguishers like we used
in the T-Shirt War
where it was the powder.
Oh.
And it runs out
real fast and then we
had more fires happening
so then we had to send
the boys, the fire brigade
to the house to get buckets
and we took sound water
and started throwing it
all over the fireworks
and I will say that
one of them was on fire
before the water got
there and had to throw it
into the water but we did
get Isaiah to go retrieve it.
He had to go to the next dock.
The damp--
Yeah.
Trash.
Yeah so everything's good.
We're still good.
We still good?
Yeah we're still good.
Man, you make me nervous.
Now and--
That's why I'm not there.
I understand that--
We can't both be there.
I do understand that it's not responsible.
Somebody's gotta carry on.
It's not responsible.
One of these rednecks has gotta carry on.
But you know what, you
gotta have a little fun
every once in awhile
man, you gotta celebrate.
But it was so hot.
I forget how hot it is.
We'll find out next week.
♪ Hotter than the Fourth of July ♪
We'll be back in North
Carolina for something
that we'll tell you about
that's novel-related.
But we're going out there next week.
That's right.
It's unbelievably hot.
I walked outside, my frickin'
sunglasses fogged up.
I actually don't remember
that happening growing up
in North Carolina, I walk outside,
they just fogged up
completely 'cause I was going
from AC but--
Your face, your California
face gets hotter.
Has adjusted?
No.
It's not adjusted so when you
go back to North Carolina,
your California face just,
it's like oh my gosh,
my face is so hot, I gotta get rid of it
and it pushes it onto the
glasses and they fog up.
Oh that's very scientific.
But if you live there
all the time, it's like, you learn how
to not fog up your glasses.
And it rained--
Your face learns that.
It rained every day.
That didn't help.
But you didn't care because
you were already wet.
You cannot just, you just
go outside and you're wet.
You immediately start
sweating from everywhere.
That's why you said a bunch of rednecks
not having shirts on but
you very quickly learn,
I might as well not have a shirt on.
We might as well be naked.
Because any clothes that you have
just immediately stick to you.
I put jeans on to get back on the plane
coming back yesterday
and I just had jeans on
to basically walk to
my car and I was like,
I remember now why we always wore shorts.
Like me and you would
go to work in shorts.
I remember there was a point.
I actually remember--
Shorts and flip flops.
I remember when we were
filming the documentary
Looking for Ms. Locklear,
we had a conversation.
We wore jeans 'cause we
didn't wanna look like
a couple of nimrods--
Dumbasses.
Walking around in shorts.
Right.
But we were so hot.
= We were so hot.
The whole summer.
That was the first time
we made a conscious
choice to only wear pants.
Did you feel like a dumbass
wearing shorts everywhere?
Wearing shorts, a little
bit but I adjusted.
I adjusted quickly, man.
Yeah it's not, you shouldn't
feel that way but we do.
No no.
Something about shorts
just makes you seem like--
And I do not--
What does it make you seem like?
A bare-legged man.
I don't know.
If they're pleated and
you can tuck your shirt
into it then you're back.
That's not the kind that I had.
You're total, you're just the dad.
It gets so hot, it gets super
hot in California as well.
It'll be like 110 towards
the end of the summer here.
But it's never so hot that
you actually feel like
I gotta get into shorts.
'Cause the humidity's so different.
Do you feel like there is a way for you
to feel cool and I don't
mean temperature-wise,
I mean like trendy.
In shorts?
In shorts.
I don't see an option.
I think for us--
That's a good question.
I just don't think we can pull off shorts.
I think there are shorts out
there that are trendy shorts.
I just don't have them.
And I don't know what
constitutes a trendy short.
I think they're a little bit
shorter than those shorts
that I wear probably.
Got more interesting patterns.
A little shorter.
I think you gotta have like a tank top on
and maybe a visor.
None of those things can you pull off.
I can't either.
Yeah well we should try.
I think I can pull off shorts.
Well I think I can pull off shorts.
I don't think you can.
You see my legs?
I'm not commementing,
commementing on your legs.
I'm just saying just the
exposed nature of your legs.
I have a lot of leg.
I mean your thigh's at
eye-level to some people.
Yeah I have a lot of leg, I do.
Couple other notable things.
I drove around a car
that was an advertisement
for my father-in-law's dentistry.
That was the car that I had,
it was wrapped in an ad.
Oh gosh, did you get paid?
No.
That's actually better.
It was wrapped in an
ad that had my deceased
grandmother-in-law on it.
Her face?
Yes.
What?
Yeah she was in one of the ads.
What do you mean, in one of the ads?
How many ads were on the car?
Well it was like the
whole thing was wrapped.
In your dead grandmother-in-law?
Yeah well she just passed
like a few months ago.
Was she, what position was she in?
It's just her face, she's smiling
and showing her beautiful teeth.
Really?
Mm-hmm.
On every side of the car?
Just she's on one side
and there's another group
of people, it's like her and
some other people on one side
and there's other people
on the other side.
So I was a driving ad.
It's free transportation,
I drove it everywhere.
I drove it all over the place.
Yeah that's--
I did not get paid for it though
and I thought it might be,
I thought about asking.
And when you hopped out,
what were you wearing?
Shorts, man.
Yeah exactly.
Well I didn't--
You were the total package, brother.
No, every morning I
woke up, I put on shorts
and nothing else.
No shoes, no shirt and I remained that way
for all of the day.
Oh I don't blame you, I'm just saying.
And if it wasn't--
It's not good for the brand.
And if it wasn't improper, I
wouldn't have had shorts on.
You know what I'm saying?
It's so hot that there's no
difference between the inside
of your body--
Oh I know.
And the outside of your body.
I know I'm just saying--
You don't need to protect it
in any way.
Were people coming up to you asking you
about the business?
Oh yeah.
Really?
I made stuff up.
But they didn't believe you
'cause you were in shorts.
And you were shirtless so I
think you kinda negated any--
Who's that shirtless man?
Is he, is that the shirtless dentist?
It's so hot I understand
why he doesn't wear a shirt
when he does his work.
Out here there's a plumber
called The Smell Good Plumber.
But the shirtless dentist is better.
The shorted dentist,
'cause technically I only had shorts on.
But the shirtless dentist
is something that,
I mean, you're sitting
in the chair laid back,
all of a sudden, you got
a armpit in your face.
He's reaching over
trying to get a utensil.
And let me tell ya, that armpit stanks.
I know it does.
I would put deodorant on in the morning
but I might as well, because--
You see the slippery slope you're on.
You just start stinking.
You stink constantly.
Then your hair gets long
and you're like Peter.
Hi I'm Peter.
I will say I had a dream about,
when I was on vacation, I had a dream.
Oh now.
This is really crazy, I don't
understand what happened.
I think I may have seen some news report
because I had a dream where
the Saudi crowned prince
was flying a very small open hatch plane,
like an old style plane,
but he was pulling
behind him another plane
that was pulling behind it another plane
that was pulling behind it a boat.
A plane train with a boat caboose.
That was pulling behind another boat
that was very, very large
like a cruise ship style boat
and then on and on and on.
And were those--
And it was all in the air.
All in the air?
He was in the air.
Even the boat was in the air.
Where were you?
You were in the dentist car?
I was in some vantage point
where I could see all this.
From the ground?
I feel like I was on a
cliff and he was going by
'cause I feel like I was eye level with it
but he was over the ocean.
Okay you were eye level with it.
And here's what I thought
in the dream, I was like,
man, I gotta remember the
details of this for Ear Biscuits.
In the dream?
But I wasn't thinking about in the dream,
I was thinking about it as if
I've gotta remember this moment
where the crowned prince
flew his crazy plane train.
Yeah you believed it.
You believed you were living the moment.
And so ironically now I'm
telling you about seeing
the crowned prince and his plane train
but I'm telling you about
it one layer removed
because it was a dream
about telling you about it
but now I'm telling you
about the dream in which
I thought telling you
about the plane train.
Wow.
That's weird.
I think you shouldn't have told us.
I think you should have
kept it in dreamland.
I think you should email the Saudi prince.
But man you just wait, when we go back.
It's gonna be hot.
I'm only packing shorts now.
Can you get on a plane
in nothing but shorts?
Is it like no shirt, no shoes,
no service type situation?
You have to wear a shirt.
Do you though?
Yes.
I've seen no signs that say--
There's not signs but people--
Shirtless, no problem.
People routinely get
kicked off of planes--
For taking their shirt off.
No people routinely get
kicked off of planes,
usually women, for having
overly revealing clothes.
Now I'm not saying I
agree with this policy
but just last week there
was a report of a woman
who just had like a
strapless tank top thing,
I don't know--
A tube top.
And she got asked to
leave the freakin' plane
and it wasn't even really risque.
So if they do that, and I
don't know if it's an airplane,
if it's a airline policy but yeah,
you have to wear a shirt.
If you just take your
shirt off in the middle
of the flight, they'll
ask you to put it back on.
Sir could you please
put your shirt back on.
They'll say that and then
if you say, "It's so hot."
But it's so hot, officer.
That's not gonna work.
I don't know if they would
turn the plane around.
From the flight deck, we're
gonna have to take a U-turn,
go back to RDU 'cause we've got a man
who will not put his shirt on.
I don't think that would happen.
What about a mesh tank top?
You see nipple?
Yeah.
The straps are low and the
nipples are on either side of 'em
and they're my nipples.
Your nipples.
Yeah.
Well for reasons that
I'm still beginning to try to unravel,
male nipples and female nipples
are perceived differently.
I mean one's acceptable
on Instagram and one isn't
so I would have to say your mesh--
And Instagram is the modicum of morality.
Your mesh nipples will
probably get by on the plane--
Oh they're not meshed,
they're beside mesh.
Oh the mesh is on the
inside of the nipples.
That's what you said.
I put my tank top on backwards I think.
I think there would be a
discussion about whether
or not to approach you.
Right.
Back there when
they're trying to sort out
the almonds and the Chex Mix,
they'd be like, you see seat 13B.
The further back your plane is,
like if you're in the second
plane or the third plane
being pulled by the second plane being--
Oh you're going back to the plane dream.
Then the less you can wear.
So if you're in that second
boat, you can be naked.
I think the Saudi crowned prince has
pretty specific standards
when it comes to dress though.
I thought that both boats--
I think that, I'm not
trying to get into that,
into those waters but I
don't think nipples are okay.
It's been a civic podcast.
When you told me I
immediately pictured a plane
towing a plane towing a plane in the air
towing a boat in the
air towing another boat
which was much bigger as you said,
but that one's in the water.
None of it was in the water.
I think it was in the water at one time.
The last one's in the water.
I think it started out in the water.
Right, were they--
All boats start in the water.
Well no they start in a factory,
then they are launched into the water.
Was it a water plane?
No it was a little
single engine, open top,
whatever, by plane.
Saudi prince is wearing goggles.
Yeah I don't even know
how I recognized him.
Scarf.
That's pretty much all that
happened to me on my vacation.
Okay.
That's worth mentioning.
Well I hate to miss, I
was at home doing nothing.
Wasn't even looking at your Instagram.
I don't know what I was doing.
Did you, how did you occupy yourself?
I'd sit in different places.
Did you clean things?
Oh yeah.
I would sit in different
places and eat different things
that was usually vegan.
I'm not going vegan or anything,
I'm just trying to counteract
what had happened on tour.
It felt good to do that.
Crap, am I supposed to
have a Rec in Effect?
No, I got a rec, I'm ready.
So relieved,
I was not ready.
I'm ready for this.
Don't leave me.
This is a little bit of a cheat
because I'm gonna rec something
that I rec'ed on Twitter
which may lower the value
of this recommendation
but I will expand the recommendation.
I will expand the recommendation as so as
to make it somewhat valuable.
Okay.
You may have seen that I tweeted
about Blake Crouch's new book Recursion.
Blake Crouch is a guy, I believe
he's from North Carolina.
He doesn't live there anymore.
Is he shirtless on his book jacket?
No he's shirted.
And the first books I ever read by him,
he wrote a trilogy called
The Wayward Pines Trilogy,
the first book is Wayward
Pines and then there's two more
and I read all those.
That was also made into a show.
And then he wrote another book
called Dark Matter which--
He wrote another book,
what is he an author?
Called Dark Matter
which is, Wayward Pines,
it's all kinda like sci-fi,
psychological thriller
kind of situation if you're
into that kinda thing and I am.
Dark Matter was all
about parallel universes,
the multiverse and navigating those
and just super thoughtful
book and when he goes into
sort of the science behind
these very crazy concepts
and the way that he explores them.
It can get a little squirrely
sometimes when you're trying
to approach things that there is some sort
of scientific understanding
established about these things
but then you're trying to write
a fictional book about them
and I just feel like he
strikes a really good balance
and then Recursion is his
latest book which is all
about the nature of memory
and some very sci-fi stuff that is based
on some current understanding
of the way memory works
but taking that to a very
sort of unexpected place.
Anyway, highly recommend
Blake Crouch in general.
His latest book, you can
start with any of these.
His latest book is Recursion,
I recommend it if you're into sort
of a wild ride for your mind.
What are you doing over there?
Nothing, I'm listening.
I'm sorry, there was a tangle in my thing
and I was just letting you do your thing.
I'll fix this afterward.
Recursion you said.
A wild ride for your mind
that's very, very entertaining.
A wild mind ride.
Yeah.
Take a ride
on Blake Crouch's mind.
Did you get it, you
didn't get it untangled.
I said I'd do it later.
All right guys, thanks
for hanging out with us,
listening at us and we'll
speak at you again next week.
#EarBiscuits.
We look at those.
Bye.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.